the corona virus pandemic is
dramatically affecting everybody
including us here at CBS News last month
CBS News foreign correspondent says
don't old us about testing positive for
corona virus he was quarantined in Rome
with his husband Andre oh well we're
very happy to tell you that Seth is
feeling better he just got his second
negative test result yay he joins us now
from his home in Rome Seth it is so good
to see you you know we've talked to many
people who have different reactions to
this virus heard people say it was
aching like they've never felt they were
hit by a truck shakes and sweats other
people say I took some Tylenol and I
went to bed what was your experience
like and what does feeling better mean
for you well Gail feeling better is a
relief I've never wanted to fail a test
never been so happy for a negative
result as I just got a couple of hours
ago I was somewhere in the middle on
that scale I certainly had symptoms I
had congestion I had aches I had fever
for one night I'd say maybe for 8 days I
didn't feel very well I had these kind
of different pains and places I wasn't
really used to I definitely knew I was
sick but I didn't have days where I just
couldn't get out of bed I was I was
lucky to have relatively mild symptoms
and then to test negative
finally twice such a relief why did you
have to have to test is that how it
works in Rome you have to have two to n
quarantine the Italians say they follow
World Health guidelines for World Health
Organization guidelines and say you need
to negative tests separated by 24 hours
to be officially freed from quarantine
so as soon as I was exposed to people
who were known to be positive the doctor
said you have to be in quarantine then I
had the test it turned out iowa's
positive we stayed in quarantine
today is day 41 41 days in the house
I've only been out for about three hours
and that was with the doctor's
permission to go to some mobile clinics
to have this test and and one of the
tests about 20 days after I first tested
positive was positive again at that
point I had no
symptoms I was feeling much better and I
was surprised shocked and saddened
really to to test positive again
frustrated to test positive again yeah
that's what's so scary to test and have
no symptoms yes three hours outside yeah
and it turned out that was not a lot
what have you been doing to stay sane
zum-zum everything zoom exercise zoom
Italian classes zoom conference calls
for work as you guys know zoom dinner
parties and drinks we in fact to change
it up at one point put on a black tie to
have a black tie zoom dinner party
because just the regular zoom dinner
party was getting old after so many
weeks but I'd say the support of family
and friends my husband Andreea has been
incredible through this I brought this
into his life and he too had to be
quarantined the whole time we've been
really lucky to have neighbors
delivering groceries and helping us out
because we couldn't leave so happy to
get these test results this morning and
so Seth speaking of your neighbors in
the in the broader situation there in
Italy one of the harder hit countries
from your vantage point I guess opening
up your window and then covering this
through the computer and virtually
what's the situation there in Italy and
and what's the prognosis going forward
we live right in the middle of Rome and
with the windows open here for the last
forty days it has sounded more like the
countryside you hear birds and insects
though recently I have heard more
helicopters I was doing the laundry and
hanging up the laundry and a drone
buzzed right overhead the italians have
been cracking down trying to enforce
these stay at home orders on those two
times that we were allowed out of house
three times actually to take a test
we're only out for a little bit of time
went to this mobile clinic but we saw
all sorts of police blockades roadblocks
where they would stop we had a doctor's
permission that we had to show that
allowed us to be on the streets that
people that we've seen rome seems to be
taking this very seriously and now as
you know italy is experimenting with
this so-called Phase two
to open up the country a little bit more
to allow some more freedom right now
with my freedom pretty much all I can do
is go to the grocery store and take out
the trash but after 41 days that's
pretty nice oh but it's fun to check out
the dress the trash before you go
quickly is Andre oh okay Andre is great
thanks Gail he actually tested negative
all three times there are some different
hypotheses two hypotheses there one is
that he could have had it in between and
just not been tested at that right
moment but he's well I'm glad he's all
right Thank You Seth Doane our chief
medical correspondent you know him
that's dr. Jon LaPook joins us but Jon
here's a question how long can the
corona virus live inside the body I mean
it's so interesting that Seth had no
symptoms yet tested positive yeah and I
have to say that it shows you the
perspective this pandemic gives us that
Seth is thrilled to take out the garbage
I just love yeah but you know here's the
thing just because he tested positive
and that there was the virus little
particles of RNA in the back of his
throat it doesn't mean that those
particles were infectious and in fact
some research recently suggests that it
probably wasn't there was a study where
the particles were able to be recovered
from the back of the throat weeks later
weeks after the person became sick but
they weren't infectious after day eight
so that's one of the things you know the
CDC has two different guidelines one
says that you're ready to go back if you
have 72 hours without fever
Masumi you have no medicine to lower the
fever you're feeling better and that's
been at least seven days since your
symptoms began the other is the one that
Seth has been following which says you
have to have two negative tests at least
24 hours apart if he had done the first
criteria he would have been out weeks
ago yeah how long should you quarantine
if you test positive
well that's the thing there were these
two different ways you could split the
difference and say well 7 days from the
beginning of symptoms if you don't have
the virus
you know maybe that's a little bit short
you know we're trying to get people back
some people I know are doubling that
it's hard to know right now
because we don't have the data so some
people are saying at least 14 days
the CDC official guidelines we said
there are two different ones if you
don't have the testing ability than
they're saying seven days from the
beginning of symptoms 72 hours without
fever and feeling better I have to add
about Seth that I have to applaud him
and his ethics when he found out that he
would tested positive
he contacted everybody who he had any
contact with including me that's one of
the reasons why I was in self-imposed
quarantine for a couple of weeks at
thank God I I tested negative but you
know there's a stigma attached to it he
was the very first one among the first
people to be infected at you know around
here and I thought it took a lot of guts
and a lot of ethics for him to go out
and be so forward and say it's me I
tested positive there's no shame in it
and I really applaud him I thought I got
a hand it to him and I think it's very
important medically I don't know why
there is shame but there every time
there's a as an epidemic of anything
whether is Ebola or whatever the people
who got infected there was stigma there
should not be any stigma attached to
them I second what you're saying about
Seth it's so important that people speak
out and reduce the stigma so we can all
get help and get treatment if we need it
thank you dr. Jon LaPook good to see you